TRYING HERE TO BROKER A WAY
FORWARD, SEAN.
>> Sean: ED HENRY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WE APPRECIATE IT, AS ALWAYS.
JOINING IS NOW NORTH CAROLINA,
RISSMAN, CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
FROM CAUCUS AND ALSO FROM CAUCUS
MEMBER FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN.
FULL DISCLOSURE.
WHO I WANT TO BE THE NEXT
FLORIDA GOVERNOR.
MARK MEADOWS.
I SHARED A COOKIE WITH HIM IN A
GREEN ROOM IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
FULL DISCLOSURE.
WELCOME, BOTH OF YOU, BACK TO
THE PROGRAM.
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS, LET ME GO
BACK.
ARE WE REALLY GOING TO GET SIX
MONTHS WORTH OF STRZOK-PAGE
MEMOS?
WHAT PERCENTAGE IS THAT?
>> I BELIEVE WE WILL GET THEM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
CHAIRMAN GOWDY AND CHAIRMAN
GOODLATTE.
THERE IS A CRITICAL GAP OF ABOUT
THREE CRITICAL MONTHS OF THE
STRZOK-PAGE MEMOS THAT WE
BELIEVE WILL BE VERY
ENLIGHTENING.
IN FACT, SOME OF THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL PUT SOME CONTEXT TO DIRECT
OR'S CLAIMS THAT HE WAS AN
INNOCENT BYSTANDER IN ALL OF
THIS.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THE FACTS ARE
BEARING IT OUT.
>> Sean: INTERESTING REPORT BY
SARA CARTER TONIGHT.
I GUESS YOU PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO ANSWER.
I WON'T.
I WILL SPARE MY TIME.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE KNOW.
OVER A YEAR AGO, THE
STATE DEPARTMENT WAS SUPPOSED TO
HAND OVER SOME 72,000 CLINTON
EMAILS, CONGRESSMAN DeSANTIS.
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR THOSE
EMAILS.
DO WE KNOW IF THAT'S PART OF THE
DELETED EMAILS?
IF THERE IS ANY KNOWLEDGE THAT
THOSE 33,000 EMAILS WERE EVER
RECOVERED THAT WE KNOW THAT SHE
TRIED TO ACID WASH AND DESTROY.
>> THAT'S THE THING, SEAN.
YOU ALMOST ALWAYS CONFINED THE
EMAILS SOMEWHERE.
YET IN THIS CASE, IT WAS THE
FBI'S JUDGMENT THAT THESE 30,000
EMAILS, WE CAN'T FIND THEM.
IN JUDICIAL WATCH LITIGATION FOR
FOIA, THEY IDENTIFIED THE BACKUP
SERVER AS POTENTIALLY
HAVING THOSE.
THE FBI NEVER SEARCH THAT.
I ASKED CHRISTOPHER WRAY WHETHER
THEY DID.
HE COULD NOT CONFIRM THEY DID.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT ALL THE
POSSIBLE AREAS WHERE THOSE
EMAILS WERE BECAUSE WHEN YOU
HAVE A EMAILS SUBPOENAS, YOU
DON'T JUST TURN OVER THE ONES
YOU WANT TO TURN OVER AND THEN
ACID WASH THE REST.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT WORKS.
I THINK THERE WERE A LOT OF
WORK-RELATED EMAILS THAT THEY
DELETED.
THEY MAY HAVE BEEN EMAILS
RELATED TO THE FOUNDATION AND
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE OF
INTEREST TO CONGRESS, SO WE'VE
GOT TO FIND THEM IF THEY ARE OUT
THERE.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS,
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ORIGINAL, THE
EXONERATION OF COMEY AND STRZOK
AND STRZOK EVENTUALLY
INTERVIEWED HILLARY.
THE ORIGINAL EXONERATION WRITTEN
MONTHS BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION,
BEFORE THE HILLARY INTERVIEW.
THEY SAID AND IT HAD BEEN
REPORTED THAT FIVE FOREIGN
AGENCIES HACKED INTO HILLARY'S
SERVER IN THE MOM-AND-POP CLOSET
SERVER IN THE MOM-AND-POP CLOSE
CLOSET.
THAT MEANS THEY EXIST.
WIKILEAKS IS A SEPARATE ISSUE.
THEY HAVE ALWAYS SAID IT'S NOT
RUSSIA.
BUT IF JAMES COMEY'S ORIGINAL
PIECE SAID THESE ENTITIES HAD
HACKED INTO IT, THAT MEANS OTHER
COUNTRIES LIKELY HAVE THEM.
SO WOULDN'T IT MEAN WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO RECOVER THOSE EMAILS?
BECAUSE I DON'T BELIEVE THESE
33,000 EMAILS ABOUT ANY ONE
WEDDING, FUNERAL, OR YOGA THAT
EXIST ON THIS PLANET.
>> YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T
BELIEVE IT BECAUSE AS WE LOOK AT
30,000 EMAILS, GETTING RID OF
THOSE, ISN'T IT INTERESTING
THERE MAY BE MORE FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS WITH HILLARY CLINTON
EMAILS THAN CONGRESS OR THOSE
WHO ARE GOING AFTER IT.
I JUST FIND IT INEXCUSABLE.
AS WE LOOKED AT THIS, THE BIGGER
PICTURE REALLY RIGHT NOW IS, ARE
WE GOING TO GOT TO THE BOTTOM OF
IT.
I CAN TELL YOU PEOPLE I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING SAY IT'S
ABOUT TIME WE GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT.
I THINK THE COMING DAYS WILL
PROVIDE A LOT OF FRUIT.
>> Sean: IT'S AMAZING HOW
EVERYTHING HAS ACQUIRED AND
BOOMERANGED.
YOU'VE DONE A PHENOMENAL JOB.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE TO
GET THE TRUTH ON EMAILS, ABOUT
FIXED INVESTIGATIONS, FISA